hey guys it's Justine and today we are
doing a really fun video so inside of
these boxes are some of the best gifts
this holiday season from Best Buy I
partnered with Best Buy on this video
and I'm such a huge fan of them and I've
done so many fun videos with them this
one is going to be no exception now I
don't know what's inside of these again
these are some of the best gifts for
this holiday season which I can't
believe the holiday season is around the
corner so now my friends I'm going to
blindfold myself open these up and see
if I can guess what the gift is I will
not be using a knife blindfolded so
let's just hope that I can open these up
without a knife okay blindfold on and
let's get to unboxing
blindfold going on okay
here we go let's go with this
it's got a pretty decent weight to it if
I had to guess what was in here
I have absolutely no idea I don't even I
don't know because it's not even making
any sort of sound
okay
that felt pretty good
that opening seemed pretty easy
this has an outer layer on it I feel
like a lot of times when I see this it's
usually some type of like camera device
or like a tripe oh a tripod maybe it's a
tripod
okay there's no smell it doesn't look
like it feels like I can't see anything
okay we've done that
what's this
it's not this is definitely not a tripod
oh
so there's a very long cable so it is
something that plugs in
what is happening down here what the
heck is this
I think I actually know what this is
this gave it away
because this is I have the same thing I
have a hair dryer and this is like the
diffuser part because you put this on
your head like this is this a hair dryer
now I'm second guessing myself this is
definitely it this is definitely like a
good user I'm going with hair dryer but
I have no idea what type this is because
this feels
so interesting like I have I don't know
how it would actually work though my my
first guess is hair dryer
[Music]
oh
oh my goodness this has actually been
okay I probably have makeup all over my
face but this has been on my wish list
for a very long time this is one of the
Dyson hair dryers this is the supersonic
magnetic styling attachments okay that
makes sense why I was like trying to
figure out like how does this actually
go on you just attach it on just like so
I can't believe this is what gave it
away I had no idea what this was I was I
was actually gonna guess like one of
those like flamethrower heat guns but
this did not feel that gave it away so
funny because I was planning on getting
this for my sister so Jen I hope that
you're not watching this video because
anytime she's at my house she always
asks to use my hair dryer and she does
not like my hair dryer I'm gonna have to
test this out first and see how it works
I feel like women and men included
oftentimes need a hair dryer and this is
such a super high quality one I love the
fact that this is like magnetic
like that's soap and it's small portable
compact I can take this to travel
like this is taking hair drying
to a whole new level
okay well I am actually surprised at how
easy that was so I guess we carry on and
hope that I do as well on the next gifts
here we go gift number two
now the problem is
how do I open this I've done a lot of
unboxing so I feel like I'm pretty
proficient at like opening box Oh I
thought it was proficient until I
realized that this is this the top maybe
can the camera see me am I facing the
right way
[Music]
yeah yeah okay
instructions I imagine
these are going to do me absolutely no
good oh
okay this feels like something that you
plug in okay
it's a 3D printer
it's kind of like a 3D printer
that doesn't come off
so anything else in here okay it doesn't
feel like there's anything else in the
Box
so 3D printer
I bet okay that's my guess mostly
because I feel like
a lot of times like 3D printers have
this very similar shape I just don't
know what brand this would be I'm not
really that familiar with 3D printer
brand names I don't know why I can't get
that open them
okay I'm gonna vote 3D printer
Merry Christmas what is it
oh it's an air fryer dual baskets a dual
basket air fryer oh my God okay here's
the thing ever since air fryers have
come out they have been on my holiday
gift guide for the past several years
mostly because the convenience of how
easy it is to make food in them also
there's so many added health benefits
because you're not actually frying your
food in greases and oils so I'm such a
huge air fryer fan and obviously ninja
is such a name brand like I absolutely
love all of the Ninja products like the
Ninja blenders and this is why I
couldn't open it because there's tape
tape on the baskets which is probably
good
um I don't even know if this would have
helped me guess because I still would
have probably thought this was a 3D
printer because I thought this is where
the items would have been printed and
you would have taken them out yeah
definitely I'm gonna stick with my 3D
printer guests but this is pretty
awesome so we can air fry 400 degrees
Fahrenheit for 28 minutes you can roast
360 degrees at 18 minutes and actually
that is pretty cool because this has the
Dual Zone technology you'll be able to
use different temperatures and different
times for each one so you can make a
bunch of different things eight quart
capacity six customizable cook talking
functions they're air broiling salmon oh
boy this is super exciting now why I
think this is a really great gift is I
feel like household items like this are
incredible for pretty much anyone
whether you're a college student you're
a parent you're a grandmother this is
something I feel like can run all of the
age levels maybe not like a
five-year-old child I don't know if you
should be getting them an air fryer but
they can definitely benefit from the air
fryer from their parents or their
caretakers so this is definitely an
incredible gift for the next foreseeable
future adding air fryers to my holiday
gift guides on to the next one
definitely not a 3D printer
give me this tiny one and then maybe
we'll do the bag later
[Music]
okay this is pretty small but it has a
decent weight to it
not don't really make a sound
just opened right up no smell
seems to be in some sort of a plastic
bag
[Music]
now it has a smell
okay so it's hanging something that
hangs like a cheese grater
seems like we have a cable and I can in
fact tell you that this is a USBC cable
I feel buttons okay there's a bunch of
buttons on top
[Music]
maybe it's a light oh like one of those
emergency lights because you take
camping I don't see any light through my
head through my headband I mean I'm
gonna go
with either a camping light
or a speaker
oh my God it is a speaker it's one of
the Bose speakers so this is the sound
link Flex by Bose I always love putting
speakers on my holiday wish list
especially small portable ones like this
because even though these are super
small a lot of these are really powerful
like you could pretty much have an
entire party and this could be your
entire music Source right here in the
palm of your hands I also like that it
has this little handle right here
because I thought this was like one of
those emergency portable lights that you
would take with you when you go camping
but you could actually also take this
with you when you go camping because it
is battery powered and does charge with
USB okay yes it was USBC I was right it
does connect with Bluetooth so basically
you can connect your computer you can
connect to your phone you can connect
anything that is Bluetooth compatible to
this so this is definitely something
that I think is a really great holiday
gift for pretty much anyone of any age
okay what next these two bags apparently
go together I guess I'll just open them
both at the same time something okay
something that works together
that sounds like cereal
is this like a little cereal kit
foreign
[Music]
that has kind of a familiar sound to it
something maybe that's not surreal and
not edible
oh this is like
this is not even fair like to give a
Lego fanatic like a box of Lego and be
like oh I wonder if you can guess what
this is
geez I don't know oh but now here's the
thing which Lego set is it that I don't
know
100 certainty and if I'm wrong you guys
can have I will give my YouTube channel
away well oh my God it's the Lego Mario
set and this is the Princess Peach one
okay okay okay this is actually super
exciting because I not only am a huge
Lego fan but I'm a huge Lego Mario fan
and I have almost all of these sets and
this is actually one that I don't have
yet so to get all of these Lego Mario
kits to work together you need a starter
kit so this is one of the starter kits
this is the Princess Peach so this works
with all of the expansion sets and
there's different starter kits so
there's a Mario there's Luigi and now
they have the Princess Peach and this is
one of the little Goomba accessories so
all of these accessories and expansion
kits can all work together but like I
said you need the starter kit so this is
an incredible gift for not only somebody
who is a Lego fan but who is a Mario fan
and maybe even for someone who has never
got into the whole Lego ecosystem this
is definitely he has just moved to the
top of my gift guide list without a
doubt where do we even go from here so
it has
a bounce it's like a I'm my guess
without opening it is some sort of
lumbar support pillow I don't know
[Music]
oh it's rolling away uh come back I
don't want to like take off something
that actually was the item where are you
going I don't think this is a pillow any
longer because it's definitely not very
comfortable
foreign
not comfortable
has a very industrial smell to it uh so
what is maybe a punching bag what's this
oh it does have a hang
this little hang
maybe it isn't
I'm gonna go with a punching bag oh geez
wow
okay I'm gonna go with the punching bag
because it has this hanging thing it has
the consistency the feel well we already
know from my last video that I have the
ability to hang something from the
ceiling so we're set in that capacity
okay punching oh
and balls this is a great gift for any
Fitness fanatic I actually use these all
the time at my gym so these are like the
wall medicine balls so you can actually
take these inside outside I'm having
like the traumatic flashbacks so my
trainer always making me take these and
just like repeatedly throw it against
the wall this is an 18 pound one I think
normally I would go a little bit lighter
but I feel like this is something that
I'm gonna have to work up to to the gym
you go we just went from an air fryer to
a speaker to Lego to a medicine ball
like what's going to be next I have no
idea
oh it's already opening like it's
opening up as we tear off the packaging
okay
so this feels like like a piece of art
some sort of Art
some type of something for gaming
like a headphone stand Maybe
oh
okay so it plugs in
maybe a light oh oh we just peeled
something off okay
interesting I have no idea
oh my gosh
this is actually really terrible but I
have this this is one of the things that
I use to charge my Apple watch am I oh
my gosh now I'm sad that I didn't guess
this but this is honestly one of my
favorite Chargers I use a couple
throughout the studio in my bedroom but
why I love this one so much is the fact
that you do have three areas to charge
you can charge your phone your Apple
watch and your air pods all in one go so
this is definitely a great gift to get
anyone who has multiple items they may
need to charge on the daily whether it's
their Apple watch or their iPhone or
their airpods which is why I would
definitely suggest this for any iPhone
fanatic because this has all of the
things that they would need to charge
this is definitely high on the gift list
blindfold going on here oh we go
foreign
like anything that I'm familiar with
it
[Music]
I'm doing this because I don't want to
like rub my hand along something and get
a paper cut
oh
[Music]
oh okay that smells like plastic
I have no idea what this is
unboxing Tech blindfolded
a little nerve-wracking because I don't
I don't want to hurt myself okay so at
least I know this is the right way
we have a we've got a cable we have a
cord this is something we plug in
[Music]
something we plug in
lots of
plastic
okay we have a this is a it's a coffee
maker because the coffee maker would go
down here
and then the coffee comes out of here
maybe like in here
it's like maybe there's like another
small coffee pod maybe it's like a
one of those like one serve I'm going
with coffee maker
ice cream Sorbet Light ice cream
smoothie Bowl gelato milkshake okay this
is absolutely not a coffee maker also
that I don't think comes off at all okay
this is by Ninja this is the Ninja
creamy you can make indulgent low sugar
keto dairy free and vegan ice cream I
mean you can make so many different
things even the Smoothie bowl like
that's something that I'm very
interested in this could actually save
me so much money because I have a lot of
fruits that I have left over sometimes
from the farmer's market but I also buy
pre-made acai bowls and those can
actually add up quite a bit so to be
able to be able to customize my own
ingredients and if I want to make it low
sugar keto or do dairy free or vegan
like you basically can make this
whatever you want and the fact that you
can make your own ice cream I'm kind of
an ice cream addict so this is super
exciting and I cannot wait to try this
out if any of you have one of these
please send me some recipes because I
would love to hear it definitely feel
like this is a great gift for almost was
pretty much anyone as well I don't think
that you can find a person who doesn't
like ice cream but I feel like you may
be able to find some people who like ice
cream but may have a dairy intolerance
who may be vegan or who may need special
needs for their ice cream so like you
could actually make that and I'm so
hyped up about it so this is going to be
so much fun to test out I think this is
it this was our last gift of our holiday
gift guide I do feel like I should get
some bonus points because this kind of
feels like it would be a coffee maker
although I almost completely ripped this
top off which I don't think actually
removable so good thing I didn't
continue to try to pry that open to
figure out where the coffee beans go
thank you guys so much for watching this
video and again a huge thank you to Best
Buy for sponsoring this video I had the
best time trying to guess some of these
gifts and it looks like I got three
correct I got the hairdryer the speaker
and the Lego set now granted I couldn't
name the Lego set but I think that
that's okay let's let's just give me a
pass there all of the links will be in
the description if you want to get more
details about each product I will see
you guys in my next video thank you
again for watching if you haven't
already please subscribe and hit the
Bell to be notified when I post a new
video and leave me some comments below
what gift is on your wish list this year
I'll see you later bye oh
[Music]
[Applause]